AINSLEY: 7:01 AND WE START WITH
A FOX NEWS ALERT.
BLOCKING PROTESTERS FROM PROTEST
IN SEATTLE.
MOSTLY PEACEFUL ONE DAY AFTER
CHAOTIC CLASHES IN THAT CITY.
[EXPLOSION]
[BEEP], [BEEP]
BRIAN: SEATTLE POLICE RELEASING
BODY CAMERA VIDEO OF THE
SATURDAY RIOTS.
OFFICERS SAY THEY WERE HIT BY
ROCKS, WATER BOTTLES AND
EXPLOSIVES, REMEMBER, THESE ARE
PEACEFUL.
59S OFFICERS WERE INJURED
REMEMBER IN THAT PEACEFUL
PROTEST.
47 PENAL WERE ARRESTED.
STEVE: THIS AS PORTLAND OREGON
SEES ITS 60TH STRAIGHT NIGHT OF
UNREST.
RIOTERS SET OFF FIREWORKS
OVERNIGHT NEAR THE COURTHOUSE.
POLICE USED TEAR GAS APPARENTLY
TO DISPERSE THE CROWD AS YOU CAN
SEE RIGHT THERE.
TWO PEOPLE TAKEN INTO CUSTODY
AFTER A SHOOTING WAS REPORTED
JUST ABOUT A BLOCK FROM THE
DEMONSTRATIONS.
ONE PERSON WAS INJURED.
AINSLEY: MOMENTS AGO SEVERAL
POLICE CARS WERE FOUND BURNED IN
PHILADELPHIA.
NO ONE WAS HURT, THANK GOODNESS.
NO WORD YET ON ANY SUSPECTS
THERE.
CHRIS CHRISTIE OVER THE WEEKEND
WAS DEFENDING THE PRESIDENT FOR
SENDING THESE FEDERAL TROOPS
ESPECIALLY PORTLAND SENT THEM IN
TO PROTECT THE FEDERAL
COURTHOUSE THERE.
LISTEN TO CHRIS CHRISTIE THE
GOVERNOR OF YOUR STATE OF NEW
JERSEY.
>> MOST DO NOT BELIEVE THAT THE
RIOTS HAPPENINGS IN PORTLAND AND
SEATTLE AND OTHER PLACES ACROSS
THE COUNTRY THAT ARE CAUSING
DESTRUCTION AND INJURY AND IN
SOME CASES DEATH ARE ACCEPTABLE.
MAYORS IN THOSE TOWNS ARE TOO
POLITICALLY TIMID TO ADDRESS
PEOPLE WHO ARE DEFACING AND
DESTROYING THEIR CITIES THAN THE
PRESIDENT OF THE UNITED STATES
HAS TO DEAL WITH IT.
IT’S HIS RESPONSIBILITY AS
PRESIDENT IF THE MAYORS ARE
WILLING TO WALK AWAY FROM THEIR
OWN RESPONSIBILITY NOT TO
SUPPORT PEACEFUL PROTEST BUT TO
STOP VIOLENT RIOTS.
BRIAN: GOOD TO SEE SOMEBODY
STICK UP FOR THE PRESIDENT OVER
THE WEEKEND BECAUSE, THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT, CAN YOU WATCH CITIES
BURN AND SAY I HAVE NOTHING TO
DO WITH IT AND PUT PEOPLE IN
ACTION AND SAY HOW CAN I HELP
IT?
AFTER 50 PLUS DAYS THEY GO THE
PROBLEM IS THOSE 100 FEDERAL
AGENTS THEY CAME OUT TO HELP.
THAT’S THE PROBLEM.
I THINK RATIONAL PEOPLE KNOW
THAT’S NOT THE PROBLEM.
ALSO, THERE IS A WORRY.
THERE IS A WORRY THAT THE
FEELING AND THE PUSH FOR RACIAL
JUSTICE AND POLICE REFORM THAT
EVERYONE WAS ON -- AGREED THE
SAME PAGE WITH, HAS EVOLVED INTO
A SPECTACLE THIS ACCORDING TO A
NAACP SPOKESPERSON NOT TO
DENOUNCE THE OVERALL PRESENCE OF
WHITE PEOPLE AT THE PROTEST, BUT
THIS HAS BECOME A WHITE SPECK
KEL AS GOVERNMENT BUILDINGS HAVE
BEEN DAMAGED AND OCTOBERS OBJECT
ENFORCEMENT.
WE WELCOME OUR WHITE BROTHERS
AND SISTERS.
MUST ASK THEM TO REMAIN HUMBLY
ATTUNE TO THE OPPORTUNITY OF THE
MOMENT AND REFLECT ON WHAT THEIR
ACTIONS ARE DOING AND IF THEY
ARE ACHIEVING THE GOAL FOR
AFRICAN-AMERICANS.
SO, THEY MIGHT HAVE
OVERCORRECTED.
WITH PEOPLE THAT REALLY DON’T
KNOW WHAT’S GOING ON.
THEY JUST WANT TO GET -- TAKE
PART IN THE PROTEST.
LET’S BRING IN ARKANSAS G.O.P.
SENATOR TOM COTTON, MEMBER OF
THE SENATE ARMED SERVICES
COMMITTEE.
HEY, SENATOR, YOU HAVE ONE
PERSON OVER THE WEEKEND DEFEND
THE PRESIDENT’S ACTION BECAUSE
HE DECIDED NOT TO SIT ON HIS
HANDS AND WATCH, I DON’T KNOW,
12, 15 CITIES BURN.
>> WELL, GOOD MORNING, GUYS.
STEVE: GOOD MORNING.
>> THE PRESIDENT HALLS TO TAKE
ACTION TO DEFEND FEDERAL
PROPERTIES AND INSTALLATIONS.
HE OUT NOT HAVE.
TO SAY LOCAL LAYER MAYORS AND
GOVERNORS SHOULD DEFEND LOCAL
PROPERTY THE WAY THEY DEFEND
THEIR OWN PRIVATE PROPERTY.
WHAT YOU SEE IN PORTLAND IS A
SYSTEMATIC DELIBERATE AND
ONGOING ATTACK FROM THE FEDERAL
COURTHOUSE AND FEDERAL BUILDING.
OF COURSE THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT
HAS TO DEFEND ITS OWN PROPERTY
IF A LOCAL MAYOR WILL NOT.
IF HE DOESN’T WANT FEDERAL
OFFICERS IN PORTLAND, HE DOESN’T
DO HIS JOB.
STEVE: YEAH.
IN COURT PAPERS THAT WERE FILED
OVER THE WEEKEND, APPARENTLY THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT SAYS AT LEAST
$50,000 WORTH OF DAMAGE HAS BEEN
DONE TO THE HATFIELD COURTHOUSE
THERE IN PORTLAND.
NOT ONLY IN VANDALISM AND
GRAFFITI, BUT ALSO THE CONSTANT
FIRES THAT THEY SEEM TO START
EVERY NIGHT.
SENATOR, WE WANT YOU TO TRY TO
DECIPHER FOR US, IF YOU WOULD,
WHAT CONGRESSMAN JERRY NADLER
SAID ON A TWITTER VIDEO WITH A
JOURNALIST BY THE NAME OF AUSTIN
FLETCHER BECAUSE HE WAS ASKED
ABOUT VIOLENCE AND ANTIFA.
HE CALLED IT A MYTH WATCH.
THIS VIOLENCE ACROSS THE COUNTRY
HAPPENING IN PORTLAND RIGHT NOW?
>> THAT’S A MYTH BEING SPREAD
ONLY IN WASHINGTON, D.C.
>> ABOUT ANTIFA IN PORTLAND?
>> YES.
>> SIR, THERE ARE VIDEOS
EVERYWHERE ONLIAR FIRES AND
RIOTS.
THROWING FIREWORKS AT FEDERAL
OFFICERS.
DHS IS THERE?
LOOK ONLINE.
IT IS GETTING CRAZY, MR. NADLER.
STEVE: SENATOR, I CAN’T TELL IF
IS HE REFERRING TO THE PART OF
THE SENTENCE WHERE THE REPORTER
SAYS THERE IS VIOLENCE ACROSS
THE WHOLE COUNTRY.
IS HE CALLING THAT A MYTH OR
CALLING THE FACT THAT ANTIFA IS
IN PORTLAND A MYTH?
>> JERRY NADLER DENYING ANTIFA
IS IN PORTLAND LIKE BAGHDAD BOB
DENYING THERE WERE AMERICAN
TANKS IN BAGHDAD BACK IN THE
DAY.
LOOK AT THE VIDEOS POSTED IN
RECENT WEEKS.
PEOPLE ARE CARRY THE FLAG OF
ANTIFA AND WEARING T-SHIRTS AND
SPRAY PAINTING IT ON BUILDINGS.
OBVIOUSLY THAT’S NOT THE ONLY
PEOPLE ON THE STREETS IN
PORTLAND.
NO QUESTION THERE ARE
PROFESSIONAL INSTIGATORS AND
AGITATORS ON THE STREETS IN
PORTLAND WHO ARE TRYING TO STIR
UP VIOLENCE.
IT’S A SAD SITUATION THAT PEOPLE
WHO WANT TO PROTEST PEACEFULLY
OR DEMONSTRATE FOR ANY CAUSE
CAN’T DO SO WITHOUT THESE
INSTIGATORS AND AGITATORS TRYING
TO INFILTRATE THEIR PROTEST AND
USE THEM FOR THEIR OWN PURPOSES.
AINSLEY: THE PROTESTS ARE SET TO
UNVEIL THE CORONAVIRUS BILL
WHICH WILL INCLUDE $1,200 IN
STIMULUS CHECKS, LIABILITY
PROTECTIONS FOR BUSINESSES AND
SCHOOLS.
WHAT ELSE CAN WE EXPECT?
>> WELL, AINSLEY, I DON’T WANT
TO SPECULATE ON THE LEGISLATION
SINCE IT’S NOT REVEALED YET.
BUT I WANT TO STRESS THAT IN
MARCH WE DID NOT KNOW MUCH ABOUT
THIS VIRUS.
WE DID NOT KNOW ABOUT THE KIND
OF IMPACT IT WAS GOING TO HAVE.
THAT’S WHY WE UNANIMOUSLY PASSED
THE CARGS CARES ACT.
I WOULD NOT HAVE VIEWED THAT AT
THE TIME AS A RECOVERY OR
STIMULUS BILL IT.
WALLS A SURVIVAL BILL.
NOW THAT WE KNOW SO MUCH MORE
ABOUT THIS VIRUS AND IMPACT.
AND NOW WE KNOW ABOUT THE
ECONOMIC IMPACT IT’S HAD.
WE NEED A BILL THAT’S MUCH MORE
FINELY CALIBRATED AND TARGETED
TOWARD THE TOOLS HELPING OUR
SCHOOLS AND COLLEGES AND
UNIVERSE AND BUSINESSES GET OPEN
BY PROTECTING THEM FROM
AMBULANCE CHASING TRIAL LAWYERS
OR HELPING OUR HOSPITALS AND
DOCTORS AND CLINICS GET THE
SUPPLIES THEY NEED TO ENSURE
THAT WE ARE TESTING IN
SUFFICIENT SPEED AND VOLUME.
AND TO FOCUS AID ON WHERE IT’S
TRULY NEEDED ON SOME OF THOSE
INDUSTRIES AND BUSINESSES THAT
ARE HEAVILY IMPACTED THAT
HAVEN’T BEEN ABLE TO GET TO
WORK.
PEOPLE STILL OUT OF WORK THROUGH
NO FAULT OF THEIR OWN THROUGH
THE FAULT ONLY OF THE CHINESE
COMMUNIST PARTY.
THAT’S WHAT I EXPECT YOU WILL
SEE IN THE BILL TODAY AND THAT’S
WHERE OUR FOCUS WILL BE ON THE
DAYS AHEAD.
BRIAN: SENATOR TOM COTTON IN THE
EYE OF THE STORM YOU LIKE TO
TAKE ON HOT ISSUES 1619 PROJECT.
HERE IS PART OF YOUR INTERVIEW
WITH THE ARKANSAS GAZETTE.
WE HAVE TO STUDY THE HISTORY OF
SLAVERY AND ITS ROLE AND IMPACT
ON THE DEVELOPMENT OF OUR
COUNTRY BECAUSE OTHERWISE WE
CAN’T UNDERSTAND OUR COUNTRY.
SOME SAY THAT WAS INSENSITIVE.
>> WELL THAT IS FAKE NEWS,
BRIAN.
THAT’S NOT WHAT I SAID.
WHAT I SAID IS THAT MANY
FOUNDERS BELIEVED THAT ONLY WITH
THE UNION AND THE CONSTITUTION
COULD WE PUT SLAVERY ON THE PATH
TO ITS ULTIMATE EXTENSION.
THAT’S EXACTLY WHAT LINCOLN
SAID.
OF COURSEst OF COURSE SLAVERY
IS AN EVIL INSTITUTION IN ALL
ITS FORMS AT ALL TIMES IN
AMERICA’S PAST OR AROUND THE
WORLD TODAY.
THE FUNDAMENTAL MORAL PRINCIPLE
OF AMERICA IS RIGHT THERE IN IT
THE DECLARATION ALL MEN ARE
CREATED EQUAL.
THE HISTORY OF AMERICA IS THE
LONG AND DIFFICULT STRUGGLE TO
LIVE UP TO THAT PRINCIPLE.
THAT’S A HISTORY WE OUGHT TO BE
PROUD OF.
NOT THE HISTORICAL REVISIONISM
OF THE 1619 PROJECT.
WHICH WANTS TO INDOCTRINATE
AMERICA’S KIDS AND TEACH THEM TO
HATE AMERICA.
TO SAY BELIEVE THAT AMERICA WAS
FOUNDED NOT ON HUMAN FREEDOM BUT
ON RACISM.
TO SAY THINK THAT SLAVERY WAS
NOT AN ABERRATION BUT THE TRUE
HEART OF AMERICA.
THAT’S WHY LEADING HISTORIANS
LIKE JAMES McPHERSON OR GORDON
WOOD HAVE DEBUNKED THE 1619
PROJECT.
MAKE SURE FEDERAL TAX DOLLARS
DON’T GO TO TEACHING IT.
THE "NEW YORK TIMES" SHOULD NOT
BE TEACHING AMERICAN HISTORY TO
OUR KIDS.
STEVE: SENATOR, BEFORE YOU GO.
TODAY MARKS 99 DAYS BEFORE THE
ELECTION DAY.
WHAT IS THE STATE OF THE RACE
RIGHT NOW?
>> WELL, YOU THINK IT’S A CLOSE
RACE IN THE PRESIDENTIAL
CAMPAIGN AND SENATE CAMPAIGNS AS
WELL.
AND THE AMERICAN PEOPLE ARE
GOING TO BE ASKING WHO IS GOING
TO BE BEST EQUIPPED TO HELP GET
THE ECONOMY BACK ON ITS FEET.
WHO IS GOING TO PROTECT OUR
COMMUNITIES FROM THE VIOLENCE WE
SEE IN THE STREETS?
WHO IS GOING TO PROTECT THIS
NATION FROM THE THREAT OF THE
CHINESE COMMUNIST PARTY AND
OTHER THREATS ABROAD AND AS WE
HEAD DOWN THE HOMESTRETCH OF
THIS CAMPAIGN I THINK THEY WILL
CONCLUDE IT’S THE PRESIDENT AND